This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Off the southeastern coast of China is the small, sweet potato-shaped island of Taiwan. Yes, I assure you, it is sweet potato-shaped, not regular potato-shaped. Taiwan is not recognized by the UN as a sovereign nation, though many people who live there would like it to be. Depending on who you dare ask, Taiwan could be considered a part of China or a land apart. Before I traveled to Taiwan, I'm embarrassed to admit I wasn't entirely sure where it was. Producer Avery Truffleman just back from Taipei, the capital of Taiwan. And a lot of people in Taiwan know this. That people like me aren't really sure where exactly they are or if they're a country.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在中国东南海岸附近，有一个形似红薯的小岛——台湾。是的，我向你保证，它长得像红薯，而不是普通的土豆。台湾并未被联合国承认为一个主权国家，尽管许多当地居民希望如此。取决于你敢向谁打听，台湾可以被视为中国的一部分，或者是一片独立之外的土地。在我去台湾之前，我很尴尬地承认，我并不是很清楚它确切在哪里。制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼刚刚从台湾首府台北归来。台湾的许多人都知道这一点。人们像我一样，并不太清楚他们确切在哪里，或者他们到底算不算一个国家。
And this is part of why, in 1997, a city of Taipei set out to do something they hope would put them on the map. They set out to build a very, very tall building. Taiwan really need to let the world see it. You know, Taiwan is such a beautiful island. This is Michael Liu. He's a representative of Taiwan's tallest building, Taipei 101. And he says the city of Taipei started with a plan for a 66-story office building, with a high-class mall and food court.
这也正是为什么在1997年，台北市着手要做一件他们希望能够让自己名扬世界的事情。他们着手建造一栋非常非常高的建筑。台湾真的需要让世界看到它。你知道，台湾是一个多么美丽的岛屿。这是刘兆玺。他是台湾最高建筑台北101的大楼代表。他说，台北市最初的计划是建造一座66层的办公大楼，配有高级商场和美食广场。
And 66 stories was enough to make it among the tallest in the country. So then the city government said, oh, you know, we should let the world see it. So we the city government said, oh, you know, we should let the world see us or we should have a bigger and more aggressive plan. So the city of Taipei decided to change the plans, raising the building to 88 stories, which would make it the same height
而66层的楼高足以让它跻身国内最高建筑之列。于是市政府说，哦，你知道，我们应该让世界看到它。所以我们市政府说，哦，你知道，我们应该让世界看到我们，或者我们应该有一个更大、更具雄心的计划。因此，台北市决定修改计划，将大楼高度提升至88层，这将使其拥有相同的高度
as the patronus towers in Malaysia, which were then the tallest buildings in the world. And it was not satisfied. So then one of the developers saying, we should go for more than one hundred. And so they decided to make it 101 stories. Hence the name Taipei 101. In Chinese, Velazvi, 100 is a perfection.
与马来西亚的石油双塔相当，当时那是世界上最高的建筑。然而他们并不满足。于是其中一位开发商说，我们应该挑战100层以上。因此他们决定将其建造为101层。这便是“台北101”名字的由来。在中文里，在“发”的谐音中，100代表着完美。
We're not satisfied with the perfection. Taipei 101 rises 1,667 feet up in the air, which is about 508 meters. It is bonkers high. It sticks so far above the rest of Taipei that it looks a bit surreal. You can see it from almost anywhere in the city, even from neighboring towns, like a benevolent eye of Sauron. Building something of this size is never easy, but Taipei had extra obstacles. In a city prone to earthquakes and typhoons, they had a design of building that could withstand
我们并不满足于完美。台北101直冲云霄，高度达到1667英尺，大约为508米。这简直高得疯狂。它高高耸立在台北其他建筑之上，显得有些超现实。你在城市的几乎任何地方都能看到它，甚至在邻近的城镇也能看到，就像索伦那只仁慈的眼睛。建造如此规模的建筑绝非易事，但台北面临着额外的障碍。在一座易受地震和台风侵袭的城市里，他们必须设计出能够抵御
these conditions, and they had to convince the public that this freakishly tall new building was safe. And for a while at least, Taipei 101 would hold the coveted title of tallest building in the world. I think it's fair to say that a large part of the story and history of tall buildings is really wrapped up with ego and competition, perhaps more so than any other building type. This is Anthony Wood, executive director of the Council on Tall Buildings and Urban Habitat. They are the organization that gives out that official title of tallest building in the world.
这些极端条件，并且他们必须说服公众，这座极其高耸的新建筑是安全的。而且至少在一段时间里，台北101将享有全球最高建筑这一令人艳羡的称号。我认为这样说并不过分：高层建筑故事和历史的很大一部分，实际上都与自我和竞争紧密相连，也许比任何其他类型的建筑都要明显。这是安东尼·伍德，高层建筑与城市人居委员会执行董事。他们正是那个授予全球最高建筑官方称号的机构。
Yeah, we have a very big ruler and we send someone on site. No, it's it is all based on drawings on submitted drawings and it's important to have a fair and official measurement process because a tall tall building always represents something larger than itself. Historically, a tall building was the embodiment of corporate power. And you could see that in the titles of the project, hence, Chrysler Building or Chicago Tribune Tower or Seas Tower. But in the last couple of decades, the agenda has shifted. The motivation is the same in terms of getting attention and getting branding,
是的，我们有一把非常大的尺子，我们会派人去现场。不，其实这全都是基于图纸，基于提交的图纸。拥有一个公正且官方的测量过程非常重要，因为一座高层建筑总是代表着超越其自身的事物。在历史上，高层建筑是企业力量的化身。你可以在项目的名称中看出这一点，比如克莱斯勒大楼、芝加哥论坛报大厦或西尔斯大厦。但在过去几十里，议程已经发生了转变。其动机在获取关注和品牌效应方面是一样的，
but it's now more likely to be for a city, a people, an economy, a country. Which is why projects are now more likely to be named for places like Shanghai Tower, Doha Convention Center, Dubai One, Signature Tower Jakarta, Mecca Royal Clock Tower, and Taipei 101. A tall tower is a way to show the world we have arrived. The question I typically get asked is how high can we go? Most people think that the limits on high are technological, and I can tell you that they're not. Really, the height of a tower is the product of its base, and as long as you've got a big enough area at the base of the base, and as long as you've got a big enough area
但它现在更有可能是为了一个城市、一群人、一个经济体、一个国家。这就是为什么现在的项目更有可能以这些地方命名：上海中心大厦、多哈会展中心、迪拜塔、雅加达标志塔、麦加皇家钟塔以及台北101。高塔是向世界展示“我们已经到来”的一种方式。我通常被问到的问题是：我们究竟能建多高？大多数人认为高度的限制是技术层面的，但我可以告诉你，事实并非如此。实际上，一座塔的高度是其底座的产物，只要你在底座上有足够大的面积，只要你在底座上有足够大的面积
at the base of the tower, it's just down to structural engineering. You can go as high as you, you know, as necessary or as high as motivated. Which means the only real limits are resources and will. The main limit is financial. That's the only limit on tall buildings really is who the hell is gonna pay for it and Should it be done in the first place In Taipei securing funding for their new building was a huge endeavor as Taipei 101 representative Michael Lu says This was a public private partnership where a handful of local financial institutions signed on as shareholders where a handful of local financial institutions signed on as shareholders. Including Taiwan Stock Exchange and a lot of local banks in some telephone company, but local.
在塔楼的底座，这仅仅取决于结构工程。你可以建得如你所知、如必要的那般高，或者如你所怀有的动力那般高。这意味着唯一的真正限制是资源和意愿。主要的限制是资金。关于高层建筑，唯一的限制其实就是：究竟是谁他妈的来付这笔钱？以及这项工程从一开始就该做吗？在台北，为他们的新建筑争取资金是一项巨大的工程，正如台北101代表刘兆玺所说：这是一个公私合营的项目，由少数几家本地金融机构作为股东签约加入，由少数几家本地金融机构作为股东签约加入。其中包括台湾证券交易所、许多当地银行以及某家电信公司，但都是本土企业。
And getting the rest of the city on board with this plan meant taking a lot of different considerations into account, like commercial flight patterns. When we proposed this, it's a big, big challenge for a deviation department. Type of his airport is right in the middle of the city. So we went through a very, very difficult time to talk to them and not only the city, but also the country recognized that we need this to really go for the tallest in the world. And then, so the end, the fly detour.
要让这座城市的其余部分赞同这一计划，意味着要将许多不同的考量因素纳入计算，比如商业航班航线。当我们提出这个方案时，对民航部门来说是一个巨大、巨大的挑战。台北的机场就在市中心。所以我们经历了非常、非常艰难的时期去与他们沟通，不仅是城市，连国家也认识到我们确实需要这个项目来真正冲击世界第一高。最后，飞机不得不改变航线。
Oh, they threw me out of it all the time. Yeah, a lot. Because of us. The land was set. The air was cleared. The city of Taipei was ready to create a building that would be the tallest in the world. Now they had to make it look good.
哦，他们一直在把我赶出去。是的，经常这样。全都是因为我们。土地已经划定。空域已经清理。台北市已经准备好建造一座将成为世界最高峰的建筑。现在，他们得让它看起来足够漂亮。
The important thing is that you have to design building to be really iconic, otherwise you cannot become a landmark. That is CY Lee and he is a bona fide star-cutette. He had already designed big buildings in other cities in Taiwan and all around China when he started planning this project back in the late 90s. And he wanted this new building to be iconic and to look different from skyscrapers in the West. We're in the city like a mochi Chinese pagoda.
重要的一点是，你必须将建筑设计得极具标志性，否则它无法成为地标。这就是李祖原，他是名副其实的明星建筑师。当他在90年代末开始筹划这个项目时，他已经在台湾其他城市以及中国各地设计过大型建筑。他希望这座新建筑具有标志性，并且看起来与西方的摩天大楼有所不同。我们在城市里就像是一座摩登的中国宝塔。
So it's more like a high-rise pagoda. A super elongated multi-tiered pagoda covered in sea green glass. We pick a little bit light green. It looks very good. And this pagoda is divided into eight segments because eight in Chinese sounds like the word for wealth.
所以它更像是一座高层宝塔。一座超长型的、多层叠加的、覆盖着海绿色玻璃的宝塔。我们挑选了稍微偏浅的绿色。看起来非常棒。这座宝塔被分为八个节段，因为“八”在中文里听起来像“发”财富的“发”。
Because that building is a financial building. And for even more luck in wealth, there are giant gold coins on all four sides of the base of the building. And for extra, extra good luck, the corners of the tower are accented with representations of clouds and dragons. The corner will have so many kind of a small thing that's expressed to the dragon. The dragons are symbolic protectors of the building and Taipei 101 needs all the protection it can get. It is in what I like to call a tough neighborhood.
因为这座建筑是一座金融大楼。为了获得更多关于财富的好运，大楼底座的四个面上都装饰着巨大的金币。为了带来额外、额外的好运，塔楼的四个角还点缀着龙和云的图案。建筑的角落会有很多类似的小东西来表现龙。龙是这座建筑的象征性守护者，而台北101需要它能获得的所有保护。它位于我喜欢称之为“艰难街区”的地方。
That's Leonard Joseph of the firm Thornton Tomasetti. They provided the structural engineering services on Taipei 101. You have both typhoons that are significantly more severe than the hurricanes we see in the eastern US, and it is an active seismic zone. The tough thing about having both harsh winds and seismically active ground is that in an earthquake you want a flexible building. So you would really like a nice limber structure structure in earthquake zone kind of roll with the flow. But when the wind blows, that limber structure sways too much and people get seasick in it. One of the ways to lessen that sway is with a tuned mass damper. A wind damper or a tuned mass damper is basically a counterweight to winds. Tuned mass damperers appear in many forms. These can be weights on rollers, blocks of concrete suspended in pools of water or oil,
这是来自托顿·托马塞蒂公司的伦纳德·约瑟夫。他们为台北101提供了结构工程服务。你们既有强度明显比美国东海岸飓风还要剧烈的台风，这里又是一个活跃的地震带。既有强风又有活跃地震地面的难点在于，在地震中你需要一座柔韧的建筑。所以你真的希望在地震带有一个灵活的柔性结构，能够随波逐流。但当风刮起来时，那个灵活的结构摇晃得太厉害，以至于人们在里面会晕船。减轻这种晃动的方法之一就是使用调谐质量阻尼器。风阻尼器或调谐质量阻尼器基本上是抗风的平衡锤。调谐质量阻尼器有多种形式。这些可以是滚轮上的重物、悬挂在水池或油池中的混凝土块，
or in the case of Taipei 101, a gigantic pendulum. By having a Tune Mass damper having this big pendulum, as the building sues and this pendulum is designed to sway at about the same rate. The pendulum will kind of lay behind. The building moves and the pendulum comes out and goes, oh wait a minute, I got to follow. The damper just slows the sway of the building. The tower would still stand without it, but the people inside might feel seasick or they might just feel unearved by the fact that their building is swaying. The damper is typically intended just to improve occupant comfort. Having a tuned mass damper is not unique. There are lots of buildings that have one.
或者以台北101为例，是一个巨大的摆锤。通过拥有一个调谐质量阻尼器，拥有这个巨大的摆锤，当建筑摇晃时，这个摆锤被设计成以大致相同的速率摇晃。摆锤会有点滞后。建筑移动了，摆锤摆出来然后说：“哦等等，我得跟上。”阻尼器只是减缓了建筑物的晃动。没有它，塔楼依然能够屹立不倒，但里面的人可能会感到晕船，或者仅仅因为他们的建筑在摇晃而感到不安。阻尼器通常只是为了改善居住者的舒适度。拥有调谐质量阻尼器并不是什么稀奇事。有许多建筑都配备了这种装置。
What's unique about Taipei 101 is the way they've turned it into an asset. Usually the damper gets treated like another piece of machinery. The developer looks at it and says, well, if I have to, I'll put it in. I don't want to, but if I got it, all right. piece of machinery. And so if there's a damper at all, it's usually hidden away near the top of the building in some sort of machine room or attic space. But in Type A 101, the wind damper isn't just visible. It's the main attraction. So of course,
台北101的独特之处在于他们将其变成了一项资产。通常情况下，阻尼器会被当作又一个机械设备来对待。开发商看着它会说：“好吧，如果非得要，我就把它装上。我其实不想装，但既然有了，那就这样吧。”一个机械设备。因此，如果真有阻尼器的话，它通常会被隐藏在建筑物顶部的某个机械室或阁楼空间里。但在台北101，风阻尼器不仅清晰可见，它还是主要的吸引力所在。所以理所当然地，
Avery went to see it. This is like the 91st floor. Oh my god, my ears are packed. Okay, now we are walking in through the tunnel where it says giant wind damper. Avery was there with her friend Spike. It is a massive, massive pendulum. An orb made of 41 stacks of solid steel, weighing 728 tons. According to an informational video, it weighs as much as 132 elephants. It's suspended by four bundles of tech cables and all of it has been painted gold. It's really surreal looking. It's like, it feels kind of dystopian. Like you're coming
艾弗里去参观了它。这就像是第91层。哦天哪，我的耳朵堵住了。好的，现在我们正穿过写着“巨型风阻尼器”的隧道。艾弗里和她的朋友斯派克一起来到了这里。这是一个巨大无比的摆锤。一个由41层厚重实心钢板组成的球体，重达728吨。根据一段科普视频，它的重量相当于132头大象。它由四束技术电缆悬挂着，全部都被漆成了金色。看起来非常超现实。感觉有点反乌托邦。就像你来到
to this gigantic golden orb to pay your respects. And the damper is on display because seeing the engineering at work makes people feel safe, even in Taipei's volatile climate. You don't need to worry about the Tai phone, even with a lot in Taiwan in the summer, but you don't need to worry. And to promote their awesome damper, Taipei 101 went even a step further. We hired a Sandio company. The Japanese company that designed Hello Kitty.
这个巨大的金色球体面前顶礼膜拜。而且阻尼器之所以公开展示，是因为看到工程学在发挥作用能让人感到安全，即使在台北多变的气候下也是如此。你不需要担心台风，尽管台湾夏天台风很多，但你完全不需要担心。为了宣传他们这个超赞的阻尼器，台北101甚至还向前迈进了一步。我们雇了一家三丽鸥公司。就是那家设计了凯蒂猫的日本公司。
So they created these damper babies. Hi! Chinese company that designed Hello Kitty. So they created these damper babies. The damper babies are little cartoon figures that have a body like the orb of the damper, with a big head and little arms and legs. They come in black, red, yellow, silver, and green. Next to the damper itself you can watch a little video where the damper babies explain red, yellow, silver, and green. So then you get to this corner. Next to the damper itself, you can watch a little video where the damper babies explain how the damper works.
于是他们创造了这些阻尼器宝宝。嗨！那家设计了凯蒂猫的中国公司。于是他们创造了这些阻尼器宝宝。阻尼器宝宝是一些小型卡通人物，它们的身体就像阻尼器的球体，有着大大的脑袋以及小小的手脚。它们有黑色、红色、黄色、银色和绿色。在阻尼器旁边，你可以观看一个小视频，让阻尼器宝宝们解释红色、黄色、银色和绿色。所以接下来你来到了这个角落。在阻尼器旁边，你可以观看一个小视频，让阻尼器宝宝们解释阻尼器是如何工作的。
With a damper like this, the tower wants to weigh in a strong wind. By the way, the damper babies aren't speaking Chinese. Or Taiwanese, or Japanese. They speak their own made up cutesy language. But the video is subtitled with all the information about the damper. In the damper babies decorate the hallways leading to and from the damper itself. It's a whole wall of glowing damper babies. This music kind of rules.
有了这样的阻尼器，在强风中塔楼就不会那么晃动了。顺便说一下，阻尼器宝宝们说的并不是中文。也不是台语或日语。它们说的是自己虚构的可爱语言。但视频配有字幕，包含了关于阻尼器的所有信息。在通往阻尼器以及从阻尼器离开的走廊里，到处都装饰着阻尼器宝宝。整面墙都是发光的阻尼器宝宝。这种音乐简直太棒了。
And on different floors of Taipei 101 gift shops sell all all kinds of damper babies who've been years. And we have a lot of different kind of products. We have bugs, we have cops, we have mocks, we have hats. I totally bought some damper baby stuff. And a lot of other tourists did, which is so funny to me that this huge crowd was geeking out about a tuned mass damper.
在台北101的不同楼层，礼品店里出售各种各样的阻尼器宝宝周边。我们有很多不同种类的产品。我们有胸针、有杯子、有马克杯、有帽子。我完全买了一些阻尼器宝宝的周边。许多其他游客也买了，这让我觉得太好玩了，这么大一群人居然对一个调谐质量阻尼器如此狂热。
The fact that it's been taken a stage further and used as a tourist object is just smart, really. Antony Wood of the Council on Tall Buildings in Urban Habitat says the damper helped keep Taipei 101 on the global stage long after it lost its title as the world's tallest building, a position it held from 2004 to 2010. And yes, the world has largely moved on. We now have an 828 meets a building in the Brij Khalifa Dubai. The Brij Khalifa in Dubai took the title of tallest building in the world in 2010.
事实上，它被更进一步地利用，变成了一个旅游观光对象，这确实很聪明。高层建筑与城市人居委员会的安东尼·伍德表示，即使在台北101失去世界最高建筑这一称号很久之后，这个阻尼器依然帮助它留在了全球舞台的聚光灯下（它保持这一头衔的时间是从2004年到2010年）。是的，世界基本上已经向前看了。我们现在在迪拜拥有了一座高达828米的建筑——哈利法塔。迪拜的哈利法塔在2010年夺走了世界最高建筑的桂冠。
And as we record this, it is still the tallest building in the world. It's over a thousand feet taller than Taipei 101. At 163 stories, it is staggeringly tall. The US may have once led the race for the tallest buildings, but now most of the contenders are in East Asia and the Middle East. According to the Council on Tall Buildings and Urban Habitat, Taipei 101 is currently the fifth tallest building in the world, but at the rate that Super Tall Buildings are being erected, that ranking won't last very long. The council defines buildings that are taller than 300 meters, or 984 feet, as Super Tall
在我们录制这期播客时，它依然是世界上最高的建筑。它比台北101高出了一千多英尺。凭借163层的楼高，它高得惊人。美国可能曾经引领了争夺最高建筑的竞赛，但现在大多数竞争者都位于东亚和中东。根据高层建筑与城市人居委员会的数据，台北101目前是世界第五高楼，但以超高层建筑拔地而起的速度，这一排名不会持续太久。该委员会将高度超过300米（即984英尺）的建筑定义为超高层
Buildings. Right now, there are 100 Super Tall Buildings in the world. In fact, if we go back five years, there were only 50 Super Tall buildings complete in the world, and that took 80 odd years to come to fruition, and the next 50 Super Tall buildings were completed in five years, which shows the absolute massive boom that Tall buildings have been going through in the last decade or so. So Super Tall buildings can't just depend on their height anymore for notoriety, and this is why Taipei 101 tried to rack up all the superlatives it could, including
建筑。目前，世界上有100栋超高层建筑。事实上，如果我们倒回五年前，世界上完工的超高层建筑只有50栋，而这花了足足80多年才实现；接下来的50栋超高层建筑仅用了五年时间就完工了，这展现了过去十年左右高层建筑所经历的绝对爆发式增长。因此，超高层建筑不能再仅仅依靠它们的高度来获取名气，这就是为什么台北101试图囊括它能得到的所有之最，包括
biggest wind damper in the world, fastest elevators in the world, and tallest lead certified green building in the world. Which is a little bit of a marketing thing, but it shows this commitment, you know, it shows this commitment to progressing that building beyond just, hey, we're going to build the world's tallest. After all, the title of world's tallest building is earned slowly and lost quickly. A lot of things pull together for building the world. It's a contest that architects CY Lee isn't planning on throwing his hat into again.
世界上最大的风阻尼器、世界上最快的电梯，以及世界上获得LEED认证的最高绿色建筑。这在一定程度上有点营销噱头的意思，但它展现了一种承诺，你知道的，它展现了一种将建筑推向超越“嘿，我们要建造世界最高楼”这一层面的承诺。毕竟，世界最高建筑的头衔赢得缓慢，失去却很快。建造世界级建筑需要很多因素共同作用。这是一场建筑师李祖原不打算再次涉足的竞赛。
Do you think you'd ever do it again? No. No. No. That was quick. Why? Wily isn't planning on throwing his hat into again. Do you think you'd ever do it again when you design- No. No. That was quick, why? I-I think the one you see now, yeah. I'm looking too high down. 99% Invisible Was produced this week by Avery Truffle, with Katie Mingle, St. Green Span, Delaney Hall, Shreefew, Sep Kurt Colstead, and me Roman Moors.
你觉得你还会再做一次吗？不。不。不。这倒挺快。为什么？李祖原不打算再次涉足其中。你觉得你设计的时候还会再做一次吗——不。不。那可真快，为什么？我——我想你现在看到的这个，是的。我看得太高了。本周的《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，合作者包括凯蒂·明格、圣·格林斯潘、德莱尼·霍尔、什里菲乌、塞普·柯尔斯特德以及我罗曼·马尔斯。
Special thanks to Carol Willis and the skyscraper museum in New York. And to Spike D'Ordie. We are a production of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, in architecture and interiors for her. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. years for. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. You can follow each member of the production team on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to spend as much time as possible at 99pi.org. Radio Tempia.
特别感谢卡罗尔·威利斯和纽约摩天大楼博物馆。还要感谢斯派克·多迪。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的制作节目，由阿克辛的办公室制作，也就是为她设计的建筑与室内设计公司。位于美丽、市中心的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。年。位于美丽、市中心的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。你可以在Twitter和Instagram上关注制作团队的每一位成员，但探索塑造我们世界设计的99%隐形活动的最佳方式，还是花尽可能多的时间访问99pi.org。电台坦皮亚。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。